[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers
my friends this is gunjan here welcome
to my 69th episode of
dirty chess tricks in today's lecture
i am going to show you a beautiful queen
trap
in the french advanced variation from
the white perspective
the good thing i like about it that even
though
let's say if black managed to escape his
queen
he has to pay heavy price and white get
almost winning position just within
the opening stage
the critical position arises after the
following opening model
e4 e6 d4
d5 and now white advance
in the center with e5 grabbing the space
okay the main line continues with c5
attacking the pawn c3 defending
and now black tried to put as many as
pressure on the d4 pawn
with knight to c6 knight to f3
and queen to b6
okay for the time being white pawn is
well protected
so bishop to e2 white trying to castle
on the king's side and by far
the second most popular choice by the
black cam here
is to play knight to f6
trying to go knight to f5 and put more
pressure
on the d-pawn
now against this my recognition is you
should certainly capture this knight
and if your opponent recapture it let's
say g captures at 6
then this position has his pros and cons
black has a horrible pawn structure on
the king side
so any end game really favors the white
but on the other hand black can argue
that
he has the open g file and
if white king castle on the king's side
then by putting the rook on the g file
black get
tremendous attack
and certainly if you are playing this
line in the tournament practice
i definitely recommend you to study the
theory
however after bishop catches at 6
if you carefully notice here white's
b2 pawn become extremely weak
and that's where more than 150 games
goes in the direction of queen captures
b2
which looks very obvious
not only black is winning upon but
he is also attacking the rook in the
corner
so that if white tried to save the rook
then black position become instantly
better
and yes indeed at first sight this
looked tremendous for the black
except one problem that black has
straight away
fallen into white's tricky territory
here white has a very cunning and very
superb
reply which sets the platform
for our upcoming queen trap and that is
bishop to e3 so now
white is a clear piece up so black hand
is forced he has to take the rook in the
corner
but after that yup you guessed it
queen to c2 and suddenly
black queen is literally running
out of the square overall
white has a very simple plan namely he
wants to castle
and then put anywhere this night which
trap down this black sweetie
so that means here black is literally
fighting for his life as he has to
somehow
try to evacuate that poor queen
okay as per the chess engine the only
reply
which keep black in the game is c
captures d4
which forces white hand white has to
capture
back with the knight and after that
as per the online database there are two
popular choices
one is knight captures d4 and the second
one
is bishop to e3
apart from this if black continue with
any other moves then the game can be
finished
very quickly for example
one high rated game where black is in
excess of 2200
continue with bishop to d7
and his idea is that if white continue
with knight to b3
then knight to b4 is a strong reply
but white played very accurately and
he castle on the king's side
well now indeed knight to b3 is on the
agenda
so black has no choice he has to go for
it
knight to b4 counter attacking the white
queen
pawn takes b4 and now
black shows his idea rook to c8
trying to eject white queen
but white calmly play queen to b3
still not allowing black wing to escape
probably black was relying on the fact
that if
white moves either of the knight then
the queen can escape
so he casually continue with bishop to
e7
but just one more and
black resigned did you spot it
well i hope you indeed see the deciding
combo
knight to f3
[Laughter]
and after that white has a very simple
plan
bishop to d4 and trapping down the black
queen
and even though black can see that one
is coming
unfortunately he cannot do anything
about it
so look at this just 14 moves
and 2200 plus rated crushed
in a style
okay let's check out what happens if
black continue with some of the obvious
response
the first move i want to consider is
knight captures d4
removing that dangerous knight white has
to recapture with the bishop
and black has to be quick in this
position
so accordingly bishop to a3 is the only
fitting reply
trying to get queen out from the b2
square
but again white has some elegant reply
which bust the whole idea
first bishop check
black has two options if he moved the
king
let's say king to f8 then after
castle the a3 bishop hanged
and the obvious move queen to b2
fails due to the very nice tactic
did you spot it
yup a great deflection move
bishop to c5
it's a check guys and black bishop
cannot take it
in the view of his queen is hanging
so by force black has to move the king
but after that yup you gobble up this
bishop
and if you count the material here white
has
two minor pieces against rook and a pawn
but the most important factor is
black's attrique is completely stuck
here
and it will take ages to make him free
all in all as per the chess engine this
is close to winning advantage for the
white camp
after our bishop check if black blocks
it
with his own bishop then this is even
worse version
as after bishop takes king takes
and the moon castle more or less
we reach to the same version with queen
to b2
but this time around white can quickly
obtain the winning position with
queen to a4 jack b5
and now rather than taking the bishop
white has this wonderful resource
queen to a6 threatening queen to b7
and nabbing the rook something black has
to pay
attention immediately and obviously
when he save it let's say rook to see it
is a strong reply
after that we can simply chop up this
bishop
which again leads to the scenario where
white obtained two pieces for a rook
but the most important factor here is
his
king is quite weak and open
and meantime the b5 pawn is also
a goner so all in all
after knight captures d4 i think white
quickly get
a winning age just within the opening
stage
probably the most popular choice here
for the black cam
is to play bishop to e3 and trying to
help queen
as quickly as possible
but believe it or not just one move
and black can pack his back and go home
can you see that
well congratulation if you find this
golden move
knight to b5
well white has some obvious threat
number one
knight c7 folk number two
hitting the pressure and black can try
various responses here
but unfortunately neither of them
giving any satisfy result
to highlight how dangerous this position
is
recently i beat a 2200 rated player
very quickly and i think this model game
give you enough insight how to continue
as a white camp my opponent plays
knight to b4 attacking the queen
i responded obviously knight to c7 check
and after king to d8 my idea was to
capture this knight
and now the matter of fact is white has
saved his peace
also black king is weak
here it doesn't matter whether black
first played bishop to b
for jack or in the game he decided
to save his rook with rook to b8
and after knight to b5 my opponent
tried to get out of this mass with
bishop to b4 check
okay king to d1 and finally
black managed to evacuate his queen
with queen captures e5
but not so surprisingly his position
completely collapsed
here i found a very accurate reply
namely
bishop to d4 and after that would you
believe
the game is finished
amazingly chess engine suggest that
black has to give up the queen
which was initially the agent of white
but let's see why this is so dangerous
as my opponent continued with queen to
f5
attacking my queen defending on f7
but missing very important
checkmate sequence
do you want to try it
yup go ahead i am showing right now
queen to c7 check king to e8
knight to d6 jack obviously after king
f8 and queen to d8
black king is checkmated so black
response is force here
he has to eliminate this dangerous night
but here comes the intermezzo
yup bishop to b5 jack
and after this every single thing
is falling off the clip
bishop to d7 queen takes d7
king f8 queen check
and finally king g8 and queen captures
rook
white deliver a picturesque chapman
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile trick in the french advance
remember if your greedy opponent
continue with queen captures b2
then punish him with bishop to e3
and after obvious move queen takes rook
queen to c2
pawn takes d4 and knight takes d4
no matter however black wriggles
as i have shown in this lecture white
quick
opening victory cannot be denied
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe
and comment and i will meet you in my
next episode
very soon bye and take care